hier les forces l'ukrainienne et bien
ont affirmé avoir repris la ville de
macquarie vin qui se situe à 60 km à peu
près à l'ouest de à l'ouest de kiev
d'après les forces du craignait n'est
bien les troupes russes ont battu en
retraite dans cette ville et c'est
important parce que eh bien cela donne
de l'air à la capitale kiev puisque cela
empêche en fait les forces russes de
continuer leurs manoeuvres
d'encerclement en tout cas pour pour le
moment donc c'est vrai qu'on voit cette
capacité ukrainienne amené à mener des
contre attaques qui qui qui pour
l'instant fonctionne plus proche encore
de la capitale sur le front dire pin qui
se situe vraiment là pour le coup à
l'entrée de la ville eh bien il semble
que les troupes russes qui tiennent de
quartiers de la ville font face à de
grosses difficultés de ravitaillement
c'est la tactique cru ce qu'on a vu
depuis au moins deux semaines qui
consiste non pas à entrer dans les
villes mais plutôt à les contourner pour
couper les grands axes pour couper les
taxes de ravitaillement et pour
l'instant il semble bien que cette
tactique cette manoeuvre soit mise en
échec par les forces du craignait non le
voit cela fait près d'un mois que
l'offensive russe en ukraine a commencé
et on voit toujours des forces
chrétiennes qui agissons très petites
unités extrêmement agile incapable de
bouger très vite est encore capable de
mener de mener des contre attaques alors
cela va aussi avec une une crainte ici
en tout cas dans la capitale c'est que
parce que ces forces russes font face à
de sérieux problèmes dans leur
progression et bien il y à cette crainte
qu'ils intensifient leurs frappes sur la
capitale
quoi